A lone whale,
adrift at sea,
a million meters cubed of no response. He calls at the wrong frequency.
Listen to the call of what is considered to be the loneliest whale in the world.
[whale noises]
This call is at a frequency of 52 Hertz.
This frequency is very unusual for a whale, with most whales calling at around 10-40 Hertz.
This call comes from what appears to be the only whale in the ocean at this pitch.
Now listen to the call of the blue whale to compare.
[whale noises]
Both of these sounds have been speed up 10 times so that we can hear them easily and
humans are not the only ones with a hearing limit.
Whales use sound to communicate,
to swim with others and to find a mate.
It is thought that the sounds of the 52 Hertz whale
cannot be heard by any others and thus it is destined to forever swim alone.
Singing out with no reply.
Ideas are that the whale could be malformed, a
hybrid between a blue whale and another species, or deaf, as
the sounds we make can be influenced by the sounds we hear.
This is definitely a poignant story that makes us think about the projection of human emotions.
We all feel isolated at times,
familiar with the idea that despite our attempts, we are not heard or seen, that we are alone in a crowded sea.
Does this whale feel loneliness? I don't know. How can we know?
Detected first in
1989 it has been swimming alone for over 25 years.
If all it has ever known is solitude, would it still miss a crowd?
I would imagine a sense of peace comes with accepting that
life is just the cool water breaking over your fin,
but humans would find that hard to accept.
Do you think you could still appreciate beauty in life if you had no one like you to share it with?